George Santos stole a disabled veterans
dog's charity money and the dog died
let that sink in folks
um report from patch.com
disabled veteran George Santos took
three thousand dollars from dying dogs
GoFundMe this one is even worse than it
sounds if you can believe it two New
Jersey veterans veterans say George
Santos promised to raise funds for a
life-saving surgery for a service dog
and then disappeared report out of
Queens in May 2016 Richard ostoff was
living in a tent in an abandoned Chicken
Coop on the side of Route 9 in Howell
New Jersey with his beloved service dog
Sapphire
a veterans charity gave the pit mix to
ostoff who's a disabled veteran
honorably discharged from the Navy
Sapphire the dog developed a
life-threatening stomach tumor osthoff
learned the surgery would cost three
thousand dollars
a vet tech said to osthoff I know a guy
who runs a pet charity who can help you
that guy was Anthony devolder now at
this point you might know Anthony
devolder is the name George Santos used
to use so we're talking about George
Santos the pet charity was called
friends of pets United okay
osthoff and another New Jersey vet
retired police Sergeant Michael bull
tried to intervene to help osthoff in
2016. told patch hey you know what
devalder we'll call him Santos that's
how we know him Santos uh closed the
GoFundMe he set up for Sapphire after it
raised three thousand dollars on social
media
but then disappeared osthoff said he
stopped answering my texts and calls he
posted to Facebook in 2016. to everyone
who helped me and Sapphire raise the
money for her surgery I'm sorry to say
we were scammed by Anthony devolder
through a series of bad Veterinary
contacts and subterfuge regarding
payment Sapphire has not received vet
care her growth is three to four times
bigger than it was when the campaign was
fulfilled she is facing euthanasia
within months Sapphire indeed died
January 15th of 2017.
after being out of work with a broken
leg for over a year osthoff couldn't
even afford the dog's euthanasia and
cremation he had to Panhandle for it
which he called one of the most
degrading things he ever had to do
I contacted Santos and told him you're
messing with a vet give the money back
or use it to get osthoff another dog he
was totally uncooperative on the phone
said bull
I can see why this guy loves Trump
I can see why this guy loves Trump
this is way worse than the headline even
makes it sound and this is the guy
George Santos Anthony devolder who has
now been assigned to multiple committees
the House of Representatives and
apparently I don't know but apparently
is going to be able to weather the media
storm and stick around for two years
despite being one of the most disgusting
individuals I've learned about in all of
my time covering American and World
politics
um I am losing faith that he is going to
be removed I uh he's just he's just
sticking around
and particularly now with committee
assignments it doesn't seem like
Republicans and Kevin McCarthy have any
interest in forcing him out for all we
know and as the speculation uh uh is is
growing McCarthy and Santos struck a
deal Santos supports McCarthy for
speaker McCarthy doesn't try to push him
out and of course the support of the
speaker is a very powerful thing for a
member of Congress particularly a new
one
where will this end what will we next
learn about George Santos Anthony
divulder let me know in the comments
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
and of course all of the clips I played
for you in this segment and earlier
segments are available on our YouTube
channel as well as on our Instagram
are you tired of the same old
off-the-shelf grocery store honey look
no further than manukora our sponsor the
honey is made by bees that pollinate the
native Manuka trees in the remote
forests of New Zealand it gives it a
unique dark Rich delicious flavor that
you won't find in any other honey it is
100 raw if you look at it side by side
with regular boring honey you can see
the difference I've got my Honeys next
to each other on the counter and it
looks very different
manukura is also responsible and
sustainable all manukura honey is
harvested using traditional methods so
you can enjoy your creamy caramel honey
knowing that the production was easy on
the bees and on the planet I've been
adding manukura honey to my tea and my
toast it's a great natural sweetener in
any recipe it really stands out from
everyday honey so don't settle for the
ordinary honey when you can enjoy the
unique delicious flavor of manukora go
to manukora.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for a free pack of honey sticks
very nostalgic to when I was a kid with
your order a 15 value tastes the
difference for yourself the link is down
below